-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Alison Roman
everyone!
Thank you for being here,
Alison.
-Thank you for having me.
-Her new cookbook,
"Nothing Fancy," is available.
And how are
we gonna begin tonight?
-We're gonna begin with a drink.
-Okay, great.
-Like any evening
when you're having people over
or just in general.
-Yes, because this is a book
about having people over to your
house for dinner parties.
You are opposed to the wor
"entertaining," though.
-Explain that.
-Yeah, I feel like
it's a really uptight
and fussy word,
and I feel like it sends peopl
into a general panic.
And I feel like even just saying
that implies that you're
in any way organized
or thinking ahead or --
I need help here.
-Yeah, I was gonna just do this.
I'm sorry.
There we go.
-I've never used these before.
That is not a joke.
-All right.
-Okay, we're gonna make --
I already made martinis.
I batch them out.
-Okay, great.
-I'm not shaking cocktails
-Okay, so that's interesting
So, if you have people over,
you batch out your martinis.
-Yeah, I do.
And I drink them on the rock
out of a rocks glass,
which if you are
a professional beverage maker,
I'm not gonna say
the "mixologist" word
'cause it's not a real word.
-Yep.
-But I feel like they woul
really shame me for that.
But this is my --
This is my show.
-I prefer -- I will say,
I prefer a rocks glass
for all my cocktails.
-Yeah.
-And it always bums me out
when I'm in a restaurant
where I order a cocktail
that looks great to me
and then it
comes in something flutey.
-It's a horrible mechanism
And nothing --
It doesn't hold anything.
It will always
spill all over you.
I don't accept it.
-Also, I feel like with this -
First of all, cheers.
-Cheers.
-I look like an interestin
person with a rocks glass.
-Mm.
[ Laughter ]
-'Cause feel like
when I'm all doing this,
-I lose my ability --
-What's in it?
Is it a martini?
Is it water?
We don't know.
-Mm.
-Okay.
So, we have martinis.
We're basically doing
a steakhouse at night, right
-Okay, great.
-At our own home
or on the stage here with you.
So we're gonna do a rib roast,
which I feel like
is a cut of meat that people
get really freaked out by.
-Yes, I would.
-Because they think it's, like
a fancy thing or that they can
only get in a restaurant.
But I do it at home,
and it's actually pretty easy.
So, we're gonna do it
low and slow,
which means we're gonna start it
at a low temperature,
which means it won't overcook,
because it's a massive hun
of meat.
-Uh-huh.
-And we're gonna rub it firs
with some rosemary...
-Okay, great.
-...garlic and anchovies.
-So, let me ask you this.
When you're entertaining -
Although
you don't like that word.
-I already said that.
I'm allergic to it.
I don't like it.
-Well, you hurt my feeling
because I'm a mixologist.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
I did not read that
ahead of time, so...
-Yeah, you didn't --
-So I'm embarrassed now.
-So, by the time
your guests get over,
is the food done,
or is it okay to have them
while it's still cooking
a little bit?
-Absolutely.
I feel like I've never, ever
had people over where food
wasn't either halfway done
or nowhere
near close to being done.
-Gotcha.
-I'm a big fan
of the 10:00 p.m. dinner.
-Okay, good.
All right.
-We're gonna rub this on.
-Okay, so --
-Garlic, anchovy, rosemary
We're gonna rub this on like
you're oiling up at the beach...
-Okay, gotcha.
-Or wherever you vacation.
I don't know.
-All right, great.
-You want to get it
all over there.
And don't --
Concentrate on the front par
'cause this is what's
gonna get browned.
-Okay.
-So I'm gonna let you
massage away.
-Okay, great.
-Yeah.
-So you said --
-Use your hands, yeah.
-Yeah, just at the beach.
[ Laughter ]
-I don't know.
Every time I put oil
on anything, I'm like,
"Yeah, okay."
-Yeah, yeah, there you go.
-So...
-Hey.
-Yeah, okay.
You're doing a great job.
We're gonna need to --
-How are you?
-Yeah, okay. Yeah.
Really get in there.
-"Oh, what's that?"
-Yeah, yeah.
-"Oh, I'm sorry.
No, I'm not your husband."
[ Laughter ]
-He doesn't mind.
I asked.
-Yeah.
-Okay. So, here.
-Okay, this is great.
-Here's your towel.
-Okay. So I feel like
that was very effective.
-I mean, you smell great.
-I feel great.
I feel very close
to this piece of meat.
[ Laughter ]
-We're gonna
put him away for later.
-Okay.
-He'll call you.
-We're gonna put him
in this very --
this super oven
we have down here, yeah.
-So, let's pretend
that this was an oven,
and I removed this.
-Okay.
-And, basically --
So, low and slow for
like 2 1/2, 3 hours.
-Okay, great.
-You don't even look at it
You don't touch it.
It's fine. Nothing bad
is gonna happen in there.
-And what is low heat?
What is --
-300.
-Okay, great.
-I think I say,
"Don't quote me on that."
-That's why you have a book.
-Yeah, it's in the book.
You have to look in the book
But like 300.
-Okay, great.
-And then crank it to,
say, 500.
And we are going to get a very
crispy, kind of seared moment.
-How long does that part take,
the crank part?
-Like 10 to 15...
-Great.
-..depending on your oven.
My oven at home is like
an Easy Bake Oven.
It takes 20 times longer
than any normal thing.
So if I can do it,
you can do it.
-That looks wonderful.
-Yeah, okay. So --
-If I were to ask you,
"What makes a perfect host
for a dinner party?"
what would you say?
-I'm gonna slice this.
-Great.
-Real quick.
I'm gonna slice this for us.
-Yep.
-And what I'm gonna have
you do over here is,
we have a baked-potato bar
-Great.
-And you are going to
decorate the baked potatoes.
-Perfect.
-Has anything ever sounded
more fun in your life?
-No, it's super fun.
-So, I like mine with butter
sour cream, and chives, please
But this is trout roe
and salmon roe,
should you want to become fancy.
-I'm not gonna --
If you're gonna do
the normal thing,
I'm not gonna go fancy for me.
-Well, I mean -- I don't -
-I'm just saying like,
if you were -- if you were like,
"I'm a fancy person
who has trout row,"
then I would have it.
But I would rather
just do the --
-But to me, it's like eating
Ruffles with caviar.
You want the high.
You want the low.
-Uh-huh.
-You want it all.
-Yeah, exactly.
-It's a baked potato.
It costs 50 cents, and I'm gonna
slap it with some caviar.
-Every time I have a baked
potato, I say, "I want it all!
[ Laughter ]
Here's yours.
I feel like I did --
And I feel like I distribute
that really good.
Look how well I distributed it
It definitely doesn't look lik
three different sections.
-Yeah, I mean --
[ Cheers and applause ]
That was a lot of applause
for someone
who put the improper amoun
of sour cream on that potato
-I like a carrot
and a -- a seared orange.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay, I feel like
you're trolling me.
-I'm not trolling you.
-This is my baked potato.
I've invited you to my
baked-potato-bar party.
[ Laughter ]
Since you asked --
Thanks for asking.
Those are sticky roasted carrots
with tahini
from the "Nothing Fancy"
cookbook.
-They're really good.
They're really good.
-I hadn't put
the serving suggestion as
"put inside baked potato,"
but I obviously wasn't thinkin
outside the box enough.
-Was this an orange?
What was it?
-Yeah, it was an orange.
-It's really good.
-They get roasted with the
carrots and honey, and, yeah
Where's the applause for that?
-Yeah.
-This potato has, like --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Okay.
-All right.
Let's try a quick bite here.
-This is your plate now here
-Okay.
-I'm gonna just --
Yeah. Oh.
It's like I work at Keens.
-Okay.
-Nice. Can I have a bite of it
-Yeah, that's for you, yeah.
-I don't quite have time.
We're running a little low
so I'm just gonna bite into it
-I mean, listen, I'm just gonn
eat out of the thing here.
-That is delicious.
I would be very happy
if I was being entertained
at your house.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, well, or haved over.
-Or haved over.
A big haved over.
Alison Roman, everybody.
"Nothing Fancy" available now!